the European Parliament's Lux film prize  is celebrating its 10th anniversary and  marinades film Tony Edmund took the  trophy chosen by M eps the three  finalists will see their movie subtitled  into all 24 languages of the European  Union this is the number of deaths in  Europe every year due to air pollution  mep s adopted higher ceilings on  emissions for air pollutants the aim is  to reduce health risks by almost fifty  percent by 2032 percent of GDP must be  set aside for defense Amy PS are asking  member states to increase EU defence  cooperation the European Union should be  able to act when NATO cannot 590 ne pas  an overwhelming majority voted for  greater transparency on tax evasion tax  authorities will need to exchange data  with other member states 1175 rylos were  killed illegally in 2015 wildlife  trafficking is the fourth most lucrative  criminal activity mep s want the ivory  trade band and for sanctions to be  harmonized